let's talk about seven causes of cancer
you probably have never heard before and
you probably also know that like viruses
could cause cancer but there's some
other really interesting things that can
cause cancer that you need to know about
so I'm going to go through this list and
then I want to talk to you about the
nature of cancer and some real
interesting things about it that you
need to know so definitely watch this
entire video
okay number one inflammation in general
especially if it's chronic in nature and
activate uh cancer and even make cells
that are pre-cancerous into a full-blown
cancer they can even increase the the
malignancy of a Cancer and even drugs
medical drugs that inhibit inflammation
also it can even come from an overactive
immune system
also in inflammation you have hypoxia
you have a lack of oxygen in a certain
area and that also can activate answer
number two
stress
chronic stress can initiate cancer
there's someone that I'm very close to
recently
that get rid of the cancer but went
through a stressful event and the cancer
came back in fact the first time the
person had cancer they went through a
stressful event so stress can activate
certain genetics that can increase the
risk of getting cancer chronic stress
activates cortisol
that can paralyze the immune system so
it puts your immune system in a state of
you know inactivity and then things can
happen right part of the immune system
is all about killing off cancer cells as
well as viruses so if you don't have
that that defense mechanism you you are
more susceptible to getting cancer
number three loneliness and increase
your risk of getting cancer as well as
social isolation there's been links to
cancer several studies have indicated
this especially for breast and colon
cancer there was a study done on 9 000
women in 2012 and then in 2019 there was
a study done in 12 000 people over the
age of 50 that showed this association
between loneliness and cancer in one
report that I read it was comparable to
smoking and obesity as far as the risk
factors which is very very interesting
so you can imagine if someone is
isolated or they're very lonely okay
it's going to bring their emotions way
way down and that definitely can affect
every single cell and their body
especially the immune system all right
next one is bereavement this is grieving
this is the loss of someone a loved one
and this can have a devastating effect
on your whole physiology including the
immune system in 2016 there was a study
done on a loss of a spouse increasing
the risk of lung cancer
colon cancer pancreatic cancer and even
skin cancer number five is depression
the link between having depression and
increasing your risk of getting cancer
in 2009 it studied this connection and
showed an increased risk of getting
cancer to the lung the colon and the
rectum so depression also related to
these other things like a loss of a
loved one you're going to get depressed
and when you're depressed there's
probably a lot of stress going on too
that's causing the depression and then
let's talk about number six lack of
sleep increases your risk of getting
cancer even going from seven hours to
six hours at loss of one hour and
increase the risk of getting certain
types of cancer now of course a lack of
sleep also can increase stress
and cortisol if you think about it
what is one function of cortisol
it's an anti-inflammatory that's why
they give it to people like Prednisone
for example for all types of
inflammation
well here's my question if you're going
through all this stress shouldn't stress
because it increases cortisol get rid of
your inflammation and make you pain free
and inflammation-free well this also
relates to another video I did on
insulin and insulin resistance when you
have high levels of insulin for a period
of time you downgrade The receptors to
the point where it doesn't work anymore
so
the key word is chronic chronic
activation of cortisol creates a
cortisol deficiency so when you have
inflammation from stress you're lacking
cortisol in The receptors and this is
why they have to give you cortisone
shots or you have to take prednisone
which I don't recommend but the point is
this chronic is kind of the key word
a little bit of stress is actually good
for us a little bit inflammation is fine
part of the healing process but when you
have chronic inflammation okay chronic
stress
chronic depression over a long period of
time that's when things become a problem
now number seven EMF electromagnetic
fields this thing on your next your head
okay talking about your computer power
cables
I mean EMF is classified as a possible
carcinogen to humans now you might be
countering that by saying well wait a
second if that's so true why don't they
talk about this in the news why don't
they recommend that we avoid it do you
realize how much of money is involved in
this
this is probably the next tobacco
situation it took years before they
acknowledge that tobacco is bad
I predict years from now they're going
to also talk about how EMF create a lot
of problems and my initial introduction
to EMF was when I was doing seminars for
all the governmental agencies and I went
into the National Science Institute and
talked to one of the researchers there
and he was the one who brought up did
you know the link between EMF and brain
tumors and and brain cancer in children
I'm like no he says yeah look it up
interesting so anyways I'm bringing that
up
point out that you should start to use
your phone at a distance with the
speaker or have some type of ear device
that doesn't draw a current right into
your brain and start looking at this EMF
situation because it is a problem
especially for adults and teenagers that
are just constantly on their cell phone
24 7. now let me just talk a little bit
about cancer because this is really
really important they've been studying
this theory about how cancer is caused
by mutated genes for a very very long
time okay and this model has funded a
tremendous amount of research but with
very very little success I'm talking
about using chemo radiation and surgery
the
outcome from those three Therapies
is almost insignificant it's marginal
they're looking at it from surrogate
endpoints what does that mean how much
the tumor shrinks that that does not
relate directly to outcomes like
survival outcomes
why because of the toxicity involved in
shrinking the tumor now I'm not denying
that there's not genetic mutations
involved
but based on a tremendous amount of
research the mutations that are
developed are Downstream okay that
happens after the cancer has started in
other words the mutations are secondary
there's something else that occurs first
okay that initiates the cancer
and this work was initiated by Dr
Otto Warburg
and also done presently by Dr Frederick
Seyfried and both of those doctors
isolated the location of the cancer is
not in the gene if it was we would have
had a cure for it long ago the location
of cancer originates in the mitochondria
that's the energy Factory of the cell
what's really really interesting about
this is an experiment that has been done
over and over and over again if you take
healthy DNA from a healthy cell and you
put it into a cancer cell
and just inject it in there that healthy
cell will convert over and turn into
cancer if you take the DNA from a cancer
cell and you inject it into a healthy
cell where the environment is healthy
you will not get cancer so this
experiment basically tells us
that it's the environment that dictates
what happens the environment of that
that Gene it's the lifestyle that you
live it's the the things that you're
bathed in all day long the genes are
secondary they're not in the driver's
seat and this is why all these
activators are such big factors and
these are all things that you can do
something about right you can actively
and aggressively counter your stress by
exercising by doing physical work by
walking into Nature by changing your
environment by taking vitamin B1 taking
adaptogens like ashwagandha being in
Social environments helping others
donating contributing all those things
actually help reduce stress the other
point about this is that the key word is
chronic right chronic inflammation
chronic stress things like that when we
talk about chronic inflammation
that's usually activated by something
you're doing in your diet that you're
consuming too many omega-6 fatty acids
or you're doing too many refined carbs
and not enough omega-3 like cod liver
oil
so there's many things you can do to
counter this chronic inflammatory
situation like for example genetically I
have really bad genes for inflammation
so I have to constantly make sure I
don't over train
constantly make sure I take enough cod
liver oil I used to write Foods I don't
eat refined Foods or greasy foods from
like hydrogenated oils and things like
that with trans fats I have to avoid all
those so you have the power to change
your diet keep that in check actively
and aggressively do things on a regular
basis to counter the stress that life
gives you including not watching the
crazy news that's out there as well as
hanging out with toxic people being on a
diet that's not inflammatory and also
start to be aware of your environment to
start looking at these emfs there's a
great little device that you can get to
measure your emfs this is the one I use
it's called tri-filled this could
measure emfs this one's simple to use
you just turn it on and you can start
bringing it close to different devices
around your environment to see
what is creating the most frequencies
and then you can change that very easily
like I did I completely set up my
computer
very far away from me I always use my
cell phone from a distance and I don't
use those um earbuds those are really
bad now if you haven't seen my video on
EMF okay
it's pretty interesting you should check
it out I put it up right here